Mark: Hi. I'm here,
for Hasbro's new toy;
"Don't Lose Your Cool"
"Don't Lose Your Cool" is a fun party game, where you and your friends can get together and torture each other until this meter
blinks red and then when you do and your friend is stressed and hates you, you win. who wins?
Do you win or the people- is the objective to get to the top? or is the objective...
*DON'T* lose your cool.
This is Mom. Larry?
What was his name?
Ethan *in the background*: Mom
Mark: This is Mom?
Ethan *in the background*: Yeah or Larry. Interchangeable really
Mark: This is Mom Larry. This is our mom Larry.
Uh... *Kiss*
Go to the retirement home Mom!
*skeleton abuse*
What we're gonna be doing, Uh, I guess I should unbox it.
*markimoo struggling*
Hey!
There it is. Now. It's important to remember batteries are not included in this
and
as far as I know, it is required to calibrate it so-
I'm gonna... I'm gonna do that
And it's important when you're calibrating it to think very calm...
Thoughts.
Okay...
*Awkward nod*
*slight laugh* There it is.
*loud beeping from the toy*
It's important, to stay still
and calm,
but I've never been more stressed in my entire life.
*the toy is still beeping*
*Loud chime from the toy meaning is calibrated*
Oh.
I think my brain has been uploaded to *starts to laugh* Hasbro's database.
Mark: Okay. *Alarm Sounds from the toy meaning he's getting stressed*
Mark: What's happening?
Ethan (in background): The stress meter is-
Ethan (in background): Calm down! *laughing*
*alarm* Mark: W-what's happening?
Ethan (in background): They're coming for you.
*alarm stops* *sighs in relief*
Mark: Am I good?
Mark: or did I lose?
Ethan (in background): You're dead. You lost.
Mark: I'm dead? How did I lose!? I was already so stressed!
Mark: Okay, so that didn't work, but I wasn't even playing the game.
Mark: So in order to play this game, I'd like to introduce my two-
...friends
*all laughing*
Ethan (dissapointed): It's like you were going to be like, 'My two best friends', and then you're like naw
Ethan & Tyler: Naw!
Ethan and Tyler, get out here
Ethan: Wingus and Dingus *all start laughing* back at it again.
*all laughing*
Ethan: Hey guys, what's up?
Mark: This is Wingus, This is Dingus
Tyler: Hey
Mark: You remember Wingus and Dingus, right?
Ethan: Of Course
Mark: Alright, okay. Alright, so I don't know if I need to recalibrate it. I really hope I don't.
Ethan: You might need to.
*chiming begins again and everyone bursts out laughing*
Ethan: Oh I know what the problem was.
Ethan: You aren't using the dice from box, Mark.
Mark: Right, sorry.
Ethan: Got to use the dice
Mark: Can you unbox these for me?
Ethan: Oh yeah sure. Pick up the box, open her on up, whadya get? Some die (he means dice)
What do you have to do?
*reading the dice*: "laugh a lot" "sniff them" and "close talk"
*sniffs Mark*
Mark: It hasn't calibrated yet.
Ethan: Oh.
Mark: Hello friend *Tyler laughs*
Hi Wingus *toys chimes*
Ethan: *whispering* Here you are.
Ehan: how does it feel to not be stressed?
Tyler: Ha ha ha ha
Ethan: Do you feel-
Tyler: Ha ha *toy alarm starts* ha ha
Ethan: Do you feel really-
Tyler: HAHAHAHAHA
Ethan: What's gonna happen when it goes up? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Ethan: Don't let it get to the top! Oh, it's getting up to the red!
Ethan: You were too stressed!
Mark: What did I do?
Ethan: What were you thinking about?!
Mark: I was thinking of Chica and how much I love her. (aw, Mark)
Ethan: Love, huh?
Ethan: Love shouldn't stress you out that much.
Mark: Guys, I'm under a lot of pressure. I'm a YouTuber, you know.
Ethan: Yeah
Mark: We have stressed lives
*Mark grunts and everyone laughs*
Mark: Who wants you go next?
Ethan: I'll go.
Mark: Okay. unbox yours.
Ethan: Oh, ok.
Mark: Unbox it on camera you dingus!
Ethan: I'm going to!
Mark: Sorry. Wingus.
Ethan: Hey guys, got the new "Don't Lose Your Cool" here- take it out of the box.
Here she is.
There's the dice you're ready play. It's a real plugin-
Mark: Are batteries included?
Ethan: No...
Don't even think for a second that they're included
Tyler: Gotta buy em separate
Ethan: They're not included
We'll do a little tutorial... step by step
First, take the strap off.
Put it on your head.
Remember: Apply your headrest first, before helping others. now make sure rests right in the middle of your forehead
That's where the stress levels are metered. Press the button
*powers on*
*calibrating sounds*
There's a pool... filling with water
I'm on my back floating....
floating endlessly
the salt levels in the pool are...
so high
I don't even have to think to feel it
I'm just doing it
What's this...?
Ah. James Earl Jones.
*toy finishes calibrating* Whispering in my ear.
Perfectly still.
*alram goes off*
James.... what are you doing *everyone starts to giggle*
no, James!! *more giggling*
No, not like this! JAMES! *everyone loses their shit*
Mark: Tyler unbox yours
Tyler: Alright guys. I've got this- this awesome new game from-
Hasbro *laughs a little*
Uh... "Don't Lose Your Cool"
Mark: Wow
Ethan: Never seen this before-
Tyler: uh, Hasbro... You know?
Mark: *hides his toy* Never seen that before!
Tyler: Yeah, it's- it's a great game we're gonna we're gonna play together.
Comes with this... and some die.
Ethan: But, it doesn't come with something
Tyler: No, it doesn't come with batteries.
Ethan: Oh, okay
Mark: How else could it not-
Tyler: Batteries are definitely not included. You have to go buy those separately.
Buy your batteries.
*powers on*
*calabrating sounds*
*mystical chanting*
Ethan: Is that Italian?
Mark: Maybe it's some form of Lithuanian.
Ethan: If demons were in Tyler, is this how they would...
Come out of him?
*continues to chant*
Mark: What is that?
Mark: Did you make that up?
Tyler: It's from a movie.
Mark: What movie?
Tyler: Bad Boys, I think.
Mark: I have an idea; If we all wear em and then the first one to go,
loses.
Tyler: All right.
Mark: Can we get the beanbag over her or something?
of- of the stress relieving these power of a beanbag.
*sounds of Mark struggling*
*Tyler laughs when he sees Mark*
Tyler: I just turn around and Mark is-
Mark: It was a lot heavier then I thought!
Ethan: So we go on three.
Mark: On three?
Tyler: Like when you say three?
Mark: Like, one, two, three, go, or one, two, three?
Ethan: One, two, three, go.
Tyler: Ok.
Mark: What about three, two, one, go? It could be the same thing.
Ethan: Three, two-
Mark: No you count three two- no you count one, two, three, I'll count three, two, one.
Ethan: Ok. Ready?
Ethan: one Mark: three, two, one
gO *beep*
ohhh perfect
*synchronized beeping*
*Ethan is shook*
I thought you were gonna die
*Mark and Tyler kind of laugh*
Oh no
whYyyyy
*blaring noise along with an Ethan noise*
Why did mine calibrate so quick??
What mysteries have I not unlocked????
Uh OH
HOWDIDYOU
Ethan: How are you still calibrating?
Mark: It gave up
OH!
*all burst out laughing*
Ethan: Gave up on him [mark}
Calibrate me because my head is just so misshapen Lee huge that it didn't it wasn't pressing Oh, is there hair in the way?
Okay, let's try that again
What I don't like died already
What
Okay, so we're obviously not doing this right, I think I know
We obviously are not doing it right there's a piece of paper hey
you
Audience go downstairs and find it go go
Good boy or girl. Good day. Good Chi
G good human being them
If
Well, that would make okay actually that makes sense because if it was over on the temple it would have a better reading
Oh, that's why I was one
but that makes
No one tries to help me here good, okay, so we're finally figuring out all right so because
as
Bro, probably wants one round of actual using it. I'm gonna try it again
Oh, yeah, we're supposed to try and stress each other
Okay, you know how you take a temperature by sticking it under your tongue
I'm so hard cuz I had to press with my tongue
But I think I think that is it just has to get a good heartbeat. Yeah
Why
Is in your title time it's dying
These guys had a revelation
I'm not at peace with it. No if weird if it's too tight
Food squeeze the blood out and it wouldn't get a heart rate. So maybe we're too tight
Okay
Wait, we should be standing why because if you stand you squeeze the muscles in your legs
Okay, I have an idea we have to simulate a heartbeat
Your dandelion recipe blown about his last hopes and dreams
Mr. No heart, okay
So now that we've figured it out get ready for another hour of playing the game those dice up guys
I'll start the calibration. I've got one I've got three
focuses Rollem problem quick
Be a robot slow motion
Seems like you're pretty damn stressed. This is your life
Okay, I think I lost and I think that was the closest to a normal game that we could possibly get dingus is dirt you
Unser all this time. Yes
Three two one state wait, that's weakness
Sniff them fart noises and fart fart fart fart fart
Flatulence big stinky poopy fart
Accidentally filling your pants with fart. We have good smiling deodorant know
Whether it's a poop or a fart so that you do
Man, thinking about Michael Cera the whole time and he really just calming down Michael Cera in
the end of the world or any version
this almost feels like an interrogation or
something to confess
The pig the pig is coming to
The piggies
All right, so this is been don't lose your cool we didn't
Not a single time. None of us
Shut up, none of us lost
What?
There's one more control that we need get out of the way witness since its October
October is the time of scuba CH. I thought it would be prudent dig up mom's old carcass
Yeah mom
Okay mom
Okay, all right mom it's time to tell the truth for one for one